>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Good
afternoon everyone.
And thank you for coming.
And thank you for being here in the
African Middle East Reading Room
where we are holding, I believe
it's our 27th Conversations
with African Poets and Writers.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb,
chief of the division.
And I am going to say a few
words about our division,
which is responsible for the
connections for 78 countries
in Africa, central Asia, the
Caucuses, and the Middle East.
We want to invite you to come and
use our collections, read our books,
and follow us on Facebook,
and read our blogs.
Because all this is a way of us
sharing with you the treasures
that we have here at
the Library of Congress
and in the African
Middle East Division.
The Conversations with African Poets
and Writers was established
here about five years ago.
And although it started
with an original event more
than eight years ago when we
had the great writer, Achebe --
Chinue Achebe -- who
was here with us.
We also had Ali Mazrui, who
actually launched the series.
But since then we've had about six
programs a year, three in the spring
and three in the fall
roughly speaking.
And we've done that with the Poetry
and Literature Center at the Library
that has been established
for a very long time,
that holds the poet laureate of the
United States, that brings in poets
and writers from all over the world.
And the Poetry Center
co-sponsors this program.
We are also co-sponsoring
this program from the onset
with the African Society of
the National Summit on Africa,
which is the largest
educational institution focusing
on Africa throughout
the United States.
It's an NGO.
And today we are going to also
inaugurate formally our partnership
with Howard University and with --
[ Applause ]
-- who is so well represented by
Professor Mbye Cham, a writer,
author, film editor, and a
multifaceted and Renaissance man
who is also joining us in this
partnership on the collection --
on our Conversations with
African Poets and Writers.
And now having said that,
I would like to invite him
to say a few words
about Howard University
and about himself and this program.
Thank you.
>> Mbye Cham: Thank you, Mary Jane.
Good afternoon.
It's a pleasure.
We are really thrilled and
honored to be officially a partner
in this very important series here.
And this partnership really builds
on a history of strong relationship
between Howard University
the Library of Congress,
particularly the Middle East
Center and African Division.
We are very happy at the
Center for African Studies.
It's a new centrally funded
Title VI national resource center
for African studies.
At Howard University
we had a grant in 2014.
And the center basically functions
as a hub to coordinate all
of the Africa-related research,
teaching, and creative work going
on at Howard, which is
practically really every school
and every college in
Africa there's some kind
of activity going there
related to Africa.
And the center also does a
lot of promotion and teaching
of African languages and promoting
also African area studies courses.
And one of the important components
of the center is a very robust
outreach program that we have also
to K-12, community colleges,
minority-serving institutions,
HBCU's, and four-year colleges.
And this is something that
we take very seriously.
It's another avenue,
outlet for us to partner
with different institutions,
particularly in the area
to really promote different
portraits, different images,
different more enabling kind
of understandings of Africa.
And we're very happy to be part
of this very important series
that we think is one that
contributes very much
to creating these different kinds
of understandings of Africa.
And we're particularly
happy to welcome our guest,
who will be introduced shortly.
But just to say thank you very
much for providing us the honor,
Mary Jane, Patricia, African
Society, to be partners with you
in this important series here.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Patricia Baine: Good afternoon.
Welcome to the Conversations
with African Poets and Writers.
We are honored this afternoon
to be with Mr. Abubakar Ibrahim,
an accomplished African writer and
author and a fine example of what we
like to call shattering
stereotypes and perceptions
about a lack of African literature.
Africa writes.
And so because we have an expression
at the Africa Society Africa
matters, and so we encourage you
to read African literature.
And this exemplifies
the work that we do.
We engage and educate
Americans about Africa so as
to create a better understanding of
the continent's peoples, cultures,
economies, and accomplishments.
So let's talk a little
bit about Mr. Ibrahim.
Abubakar Adam Ibrahim
was born in Jos, Nigeria.
Growing up he always had an
intrinsic desire to write and,
encouraged by his brother,
he did just that.
He has written exceptional
pieces of literature.
His debut collection of short
stories, The Whispering Trees,
was listed for the Etisalat
Prize for Literature in 2014
with a title story
that was short-listed
for Caine Prize for African writing.
His debut novel, Season of Crimson
Blossom, was published in the UK
by Cassava Republic Press and
tells the captivating story
of an elicit affair between a devout
55-year-old widow and grandmother
and a street gang leader.
It takes place in a
conservative Muslim community
in northern Nigeria, set against
the backdrop of political unrest.
But Mr. Ibrahim has been the
recipient and has won many awards
and accolades, including a BBC
African Prize among other awards,
and a Gabriel Garcia Marquez fellow
and a -- just a second here --
Civitella Ranieri fellow.
He was also named in 2014 at
the Hay Festival Africa 39 list
of the most promising
writers under the age of 40
who have defined the
future of African writing.
And I'm sure you will
see that shortly.
He's also the recipient of
the 2016 Goethe-Institut
and Sylt Foundation
African Residency Award.
And I was also able to get
for your own information --
I asked him to tell me
something that's not
in here, share with us a hobby.
And he says to me that he
enjoys watching only Barcelona.
So.
[ Laughter ]
So join me in welcoming Mr. Ibrahim.
[ Applause ]
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: Hello.
Good afternoon.
I'm delighted to be here after
Patricia somehow contrived
to extract [inaudible] vital
piece of information from me.
It is a pleasure being here.
[Inaudible] wonderful people in
the audience to listen to me read.
I've been told I'm supposed
to read for 15, 20 minutes.
So I don't have much time,
so I must get onto it.
So like Patricia said, the book is
principally about the relationship
between a 55-year-old widow
and a street gang leader
who is 30 years younger than her.
And it's set against the backdrop
of [inaudible] in northern Nigeria.
So the first section
I'm going to read talks
about a character whose
name is Fa'iza.
She's 15. But she's been
traumatized by some of the tensions,
but no one really understands
what she's going through.
But this is what happened to her.
So that November morning, she knew
she wanted to be by his side --
by her father's side --
when the news reached them.
He had returned from the
dawn prayers and was hoping
to catch the results of the
previous day's elections
on the BBC Hausa Service.
He had just turned on
his shortwave radio
when a neighbor, Umaru
Sanda, barged in.
"What are you still doing here
when the whole town has gone gaga?"
But because not even Umaru Sanda's
dimwit wife paid much attention
to Umaru Sanda, her father
hadn't taken any notice.
How could there be another riot
when so many policemen had been
deployed for the elections?
But the sounds of gunshots drawing
ever closer vindicated Sanda,
who had since left to
evacuate his family.
Because they had lived through
riots in 2001, 2002, and 2004,
they knew their neighborhood
was not safe.
Their likes were far outnumbered.
So Mua'zu started packing up
valuables, and Jamilu tried
to roll the mattress off the bed.
Amina clung to her mother's
wrapper, both were crying.
Gunshots thundered close by.
Then the banshee screams of
Umaru Sanda's wife leapt at them
from across the fence and
shredded, with decided finality,
any hope they had of the unfolding
nightmare ending before it
fully manifested.
"Where is he?
Where is he?"
There was a heavy bang on the door.
Amidst so much screaming
and so many enraged voices,
no one could be certain
what was happening.
Mua'zu snapped out
of his stupor first.
"The bathroom, quick."
It was the sound of desperation
in her father's voice
that struck Fa'iza.
And when she tried
to look into his eyes
for some reassurance,
he turned his face away.
They crammed into the bathroom, all
five of them, and locked the door.
In the small space, they waited,
like the cows Fa'iza had seen packed
into open trucks at
the Yan Awaki market
on their way to the slaughterhouse.
The smell of overnight piss
still waiting to be flushed
in the toilet bowl swelled.
But above it the raw stench of
fear made Fa'iza's head turn.
She wanted to bend down
but bumped into Jamilu.
"Watch it."
It was a whisper.
"Shush." Even in that
whispered word,
there was anxiety in
her father's voice.
Amina began whimpering and would
have started wailing but for Asabe,
who held her tightly, hushing her
and suppressing her own cries.
"Keep her quiet."
Now there was anger
in Mua'zu's voice.
Asabe held the girl and
clasped a hand over her mouth.
Then she herself started whimpering,
her steady drone filling
the silence.
Jamilu wriggled his way to the top
of the toilet bowel and squatted,
resting his weight on his legs.
Fa'iza heaved and wriggled into
the little space her brother
had vacated.
When they heard the front door being
bashed in, Asabe's stomach rumbled
like a disgruntled volcano.
"I want to use the toilet."
Jamilu's foot slipped and he
hurtled into his father's back.
They crashed into the door.
The commotion outside
blanketed the noise
and they waited, holding
their breath.
"Ayatul Qursiy," Mua'zu ordered.
Fa'iza mechanically started
reciting the verse from memory.
"In the toilet?"
Jamilu was incredulous.
"In your hearts."
But they froze as they heard
the doors being broken down
and furniture overturned;
the crash of the TV
and the splintering of glass.
Some maniac hacked at the wall with
a machete, the angry sound of metal
on concrete and his hate-filled
scream jarring Fa'iza's nerves.
The warm smell of shit
bloated and filled the room.
Fa'iza turned to her mother and
saw her mouth moving mindlessly,
her face, in the dim light,
glistening with tears and sweat.
Fa'iza felt a hand searching for
hers and knew it was her father.
He squeezed it and quickly let go.
But she still sensed the trembling.
When they broke down the bathroom
door, her father went first,
hands raised above his head.
Fa'iza felt a warm liquid run down
her thighs and pool around her feet.
"Spare my children, please."
Mua'zu knelt down before the armed
mob that had invaded the house.
"Kill him.
Kill him. What are you waiting for?"
It was a woman.
Fa'iza knew then that she
would never forget the voice
of that woman.
She would never forget
the hate in it.
She perceived the contagious
nature of hate that makes one want
to murder people they have
never interacted with.
Or people with whom they have
eaten from the same bowl,
mourned alongside and
shared laughter,
people with whom they have nurtured
the verdant canopy of a friendship
that was on occasions
closer to kinship.
But that woman's voice, in
one sweep, ripped that canopy,
letting the pieces fall heavily,
like shredded foliage
around their feet.
Fa'iza stepped forward and
saw the face of Jacob James,
her math teacher, who
always dressed smartly --
his shirt ironed and tucked
in with a neatly knotted tie.
The students made fun
of his sturdy brogues
because they had never seen
him wear any other shoes.
He always smiled at their jokes.
But that morning, he
was not smiling.
His face, made fierce by war paint,
glistened with sweat and opium
as he raised his machete
and brought it down.
Bright, red blood, warm and sticky,
splashed across Fa'iza's face
and dotted, in a fine spray,
the shell-pink night dress
that her father had bought her.
So that was the first
section I'm going to read.
I have an aversion for
depicting violence in my works,
but because there's a lot of
violence going on in Nigeria
as a whole and in the
north especially,
it kind of forms an important
background to the story.
So I'm going to read a
different section now.
Like I said, at the heart of
the story there's this affair
between a 55-year-old woman who
is a devout Muslim, a mother,
and a grandmother with a gang leader
who is 30 years younger than her.
So in spite of this violence going
on, people still live or attempt
to live as normally as they can.
And it can't stop people
from falling in love,
from having relationships,
even in refugee camps.
So this is an encounter between
Binta, who is the main character
in the novel, and her
lover, Hausa Reza.
She drifted, almost weightlessly,
in the pungent smell of weed.
It was only when she opened her
eyes and saw him sitting shirtless
by the window, puffing
on the joint in his hand,
that she realized where she was.
Binta stretched and yawned.
"Hassan, stop smoking that thing
in here, you could get arrested.
Besides, it's giving me a headache."
With his back turned to her,
she could not see his face.
She propped herself up on
her elbow and remembered
that she was naked under the sheet.
Her clothes were on the
chair across the room.
She had taken them off
one after the other
and folded them carefully
while he had waited on the bed.
"Just action."
She smiled at the now familiar
tingling that thawed her incise
as she did up the hook of her bra.
"You must have been on something."
He turned to her and smiled and
she saw how handsome he looked,
how his glazed eyes
seemed so peaceful and
yet so far away, how
young he really was.
"Action zalla."
He raised a joint at her before
putting it back to his lips.
He looked at her, then
turned back to the window
and watched the sprinklers
watering the lawn.
"God, what am I doing?"
Her voice was low because
she was addressing herself.
"What?" "I don't know.
You are so young, Hassan.
I don't know if this is right."
"Why must it be right?"
He spoke with a timber in his voice,
the one she had come to associate
with what she had called
his inner self:
The dreamy-eyed philosopher
awakened by ganja fumes.
"Why must anything
be right or wrong?
Why can't things be
just the way they are?"
She sighed.
"When you smoke this thing, I
don't know what it does to you,
you just talk rubbish sometimes."
He smiled and put the
joint to his lips.
"Maybe you should try it."
"God forbid.
I want you to quit,
it's killing you."
He shrugged.
"What doesn't?
I will die when I die.
We all will, you understand?"
Binta sighed again.
"My daughter was saying
something earlier today,
about some stupid flower that
waits a lifetime to bloom.
Thirty years, she said.
And when it, after all those
years, it smells like a corpse."
"Ha ha. What sort of
flower is that?"
"I was just thinking how
much like that flower I am.
I have waited my whole life to feel
as I do when I'm with you, you know?
I shouldn't be telling you
such things, but I just need
to get it off my chest, you know?
No one has ever made
me feel this way.
But like that flower, after
all those years waiting,
when I bloom, it doesn't feel right.
I don't know if you understand me."
He continued to puff on the joint,
looking disturbingly peaceful.
"You mean it stinks."
She surprised herself
with her laughter.
It rocked her.
She laughed for a while,
sniffling as she did.
When she managed to stop,
she wiped away the tears
from the corners of her eyes.
But they wouldn't stop, even
after she no longer felt amused.
That was how she knew
she was actually crying.
Save the occasional movements
of his hands to guide the joint
to his lips, he kept still,
as if reading the cipher
in the curling fumes.
It took him a while to speak.
"You know, when I was a young
boy, there was this Eid day,
and we were so excited
with our new clothes.
There was this cheap brocade
our father brought for us,
it was called Shonekan, it was kind
of in vogue then, you understand."
She knew it; she had bought it
for her children, too, around '93.
It had been a fallout from
the political campaigns
when the borders had been
opened to cheap commodities
that politicians had
used to entice voters.
All sorts of things had
come in: Salt, sugar,
strange soaps with too much
soda that scalded the hands
and bleached clothes,
cheap shiny fabrics
that colored the water
they were to be washed in;
petrol with blue, pink,
and green hues.
But the elections had been
annulled when the military decided
against handing over
to the civilians.
Instead Shonekan was put in
charge until he was upended
in a palace coup not long after.
His name was given to all
the strange commodities
that traders had hoarded
from the political campaigns
and which flooded the markets as
soon as the politicking was over.
"Mine was white, sparkling
and starched.
We had just returned from the Eid
and I was going to take it off
so I wouldn't stain it while I
ate rice and stew, you understand?
Then Aminu, my little
brother; my half-brother,
accidentally spilled ink on it."
He smoked his joint until she
realized he had finished his story.
When he turned to her
and saw a perplexed face,
he smiled with glazed eyes.
"We are like clothes,
you understand.
We get rumpled and creased and
torn, sometimes irreparably.
Some of us are stitched
up, patched up.
Others are discarded.
Some clothes are fortunate.
Others are not.
They are born into
misfortune and ink spills
and whatnots, you understand?"
She rolled her eyes, chasing
the meaning of what he had said.
"Hassan Reza, you are high."
He raised the stub in his
hand in acknowledgement
and took one long last drag.
"You really need to
give up these things.
Be a good man, for God's sake."
"I am what I am."
He crushed the stub in the
ashtray and turned to her.
"And what about that issue,
about going back to school?"
He wagged a finger
in front of his face.
"No talk, just action,
you understand."
"Seriously, Hassan."
"No, not now, please.
I have an important
assignment from my boss.
Maybe after that."
"What assignment?"
"Very important, you understand.
Very important."
So that is the second
section of the reading.
Lastly, I'll read -- so
the whole of this story,
this relationship takes place
in a very [inaudible] community.
It's a very close society
where everyone sort
of knows what everyone is doing.
So eventually this affair
between Binta and Reza is exposed.
And this is what happened when
some women found out about it.
Following the incident at Laraba's,
thoughts of entirely
forfeiting her studies
at the madrasa had
crossed her mind overnight.
But realizing that her silence
would have encouraged these rumors,
burying her in shame, Binta
decided to face her accusers and,
before it grew any worse,
put an end to their malice.
She was still thinking
of the shari'ah's ruling
on falsely accusing
decent women of depravity
when she reached the madrasa
and found two groups of women.
One was huddled around Mariya while
she tried to interest them in wares
from the huge bag beneath her desk;
make-up kits, perfumes from Arabia,
henna from India, bottled
honey and the usual variety
of sex boosters and creams.
Another group had formed at the
back, clustered around Mallama Umma,
going over the previous lessons
under the guidance of the matron.
Ustaz Nura was not in class,
neither was his wife, Murja.
Binta was enthralled by some
of the wares on Mariya's desk
and reached for a jar of pure honey.
When she asked if it was definitely
pure, Mariya scowled at her.
"Well, it isn't adulterated,
if that's what you mean."
The other women turned to her.
Binta felt cowed by the attention.
"Well, you know, sometimes
people do add sugar."
"Binta, keep [inaudible]
if you are not buying.
Who are you to come
here with accusations?
Imagine the hyena calling the
dog a savage," Mariya hissed.
That wasn't how Binta imagined
the scenario would play out,
and before she could
marshal her thoughts, Ladidi,
the skinny woman famed for
her half-dozen divorces
and her children fathered
by as many men,
waved her hand before her
nose and cleared her throat.
"What is that God-awful smell?"
The women sniffed the air and,
having failed to perceive
it, they turned to Ladidi.
After an appropriate interval, in
which Ladidi savored the attention,
she made a declaration that
stunned the entire class,
including Mallama Umma's
earnest group devoted
to the study of hadith at the rear.
"It's the smell of zina, wallahi.
I could perceive it from anywhere.
There is a fornicator
in this class."
And she spat and turned
her back to the slimy mucus
that slid sordidly down the wall.
"Who are you calling
a fornicator, Ladidi?
Are you making false
accusations against me?
Can you prove anything?"
Ladidi chuckled.
"Who mentioned your name?"
she hissed.
"But did they not say a guilty
person would sweat even in the rain?
Aikin banza."
Binta put down the bottle
of honey on the table and,
in the heavy silence that followed,
walked to her seat in
the middle of class.
She sat down and bowed her head.
But then Shafa'atu, the young bride
who was stationed just behind her
and was queasy already with
the burgeoning seed inside her,
got up abruptly and knocked
over her bag in the process.
She gathered her books from
the floor and, holding her hand
over her mouth, hurried
out of the class.
Ladidi Hassan adjusted her
hijab, spat on the floor,
cast a sidelong glance at Binta,
whose head was still bowed,
and walked out of the class.
Two other women followed her.
And then Mallama Umma
resumed her tutorials
with her voice made unnecessarily
loud as to take in the entire class
and with the fervor that was
driven by restrained furry.
Binta could hear her, but
she was not listening.
The words cascaded off her
consciousness and registered only
in the background of her thoughts.
Her mind was numbed by the
recollection of the silence
that had accompanied
her to her seat.
Her vision was blurred by the film
of tears that lingered in her eyes
because she would not let
them run down her cheeks.
She had no idea how long she
sat like that: Head bowed,
tears imprisoned in her eyes, and
a whistling silence in her mind.
When she stood up,
she became conscious
of the abrupt silence around her.
She picked up her bag and
walked out with as much dignity
as she could muster,
her pace measured,
her shoulders held
straight, defiant even.
But inside, she could feel
the weight of her heart.
And it felt so much heavier
than she ever remembered.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Patricia Baine: But
before starting my questions,
I'd like to congratulate you
on your most recent award,
the Nigerian Prize for Literature,
the 2016 Nigerian Prize
for Literature.
Congratulations on that.
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim:
Thank you very much.
>> Patricia Baine:
And congratulations
on a beautiful story.
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: Thank you.
>> Patricia Baine: My
first question would be:
When did you actually start
writing and why did you turn
to the novel as a literary genre?
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: When
did I start writing as general
or when did I start
writing this book?
>> Patricia Baine: In general.
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim:
In general.
I wish I can remember.
>> Patricia Baine: It can't
be that far back [Laughs].
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: Well,
for someone who has lived as long
as I have, which is not very long,
but this is something
I've always been doing.
I've always been interested in
telling stories, in, you know,
somehow capturing a narrative.
Even before I could write,
I was drawing pictures
that somehow connected
and formed a story,
you know, have this narrative act.
And then when I could read
and write, I just took off.
You know? So yeah, I think
at the points I consciously
started writing I was 13, you know.
By the time I was 18 I was
sure it was what I wanted to do
with the rest of my life.
So here we are [Laughs].
Yeah.
>> Patricia Baine: In
a previous interview,
you noted that northern Nigeria
is severely underrepresented
in the canon of Nigerian literature.
Now, northern Nigeria has a
literary tradition dating back,
what, ninth, tenth century?
So is there a uniqueness in northern
Nigeria literature and particularly
in the present climate of
northern Nigeria literature?
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: Well,
when you talk about
northern Nigerian literature,
it has a history.
You know? You've been to Nigeria
before and you know the history
of writing in the north of Nigeria,
which dates back for ages, you know.
But the thing is this,
the literature you find is written
mostly in what is called Ajani,
which is using Arabic letters
to capture words and
phrases [inaudible].
And that dates back to
-- I don't know how long.
The Arabs first came to the north
of Nigeria in the 14th century,
so that influenced us in there.
What you've had is that
there has been a tradition
of writing in the north.
I remember in the ninth,
tenth century there was a German
translation of a love poem
from Hausa into German
by a German explorer
who happened to travel to the north.
So there has been this
history of writing.
And most recently you have
this huge literature in Hausa
that has been produced, which
is something I've [inaudible]
in this book.
It's called the Soyayya novels.
Mostly they're love
stories written by women,
but they are written in Hausa.
So it is for the consumption
of people who speak Hausa.
So it's essentially the
north talking to itself
about the north, about
their own issues.
But when you talk about
Nigerian literature in English,
there is a shortage of material
from the north of Nigeria.
So I felt it was important to
kind of drag the north of Nigeria
into the mainstream of Nigerian
literature in that sense and,
you know, start up
conversations about people.
Because there's a lot of
misunderstanding, if you like,
of why the different
people of Nigeria, you know,
people in the east have
different ideas about the people
in the north and vice versa.
So it's all over the place.
And I felt that literature is one
of the ways that we could break
down these barriers and create
that understanding of people.
But because the north is not
writing its own stories in a way
that people outside of that
region would understand,
there is this constant should
I say projection of stereotypes
and stale ideas that
are not essentially true
about the region, about its people.
So that was what I
wanted to do [inaudible].
>> Patricia Baine: Okay.
Now, in your debut novel,
you're speaking quite openly
about female sexuality, which is
pretty much a socially taboo subject
in northern Nigeria.
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: Yeah.
>> Patricia Baine: You also address
a number of other social issues.
So what, really, was your
intent in writing this novel?
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim:
Well, the principal intent was
to tell a good story --
principally that was the intent.
But then along the line you
realize that as you are trying
to capture the story of these
two characters who happen
to have this relationship across
class divide and all that,
all that [inaudible] come into play.
Because they are from different age,
they are from different backgrounds,
the social cultural context has
to have an impact, you know?
And all these things came
together in the narration,
in how the story played out,
and how the characters think
and how they behave in essence.
So yeah, that was essentially
the principal objective,
to tell a good story.
Yeah, talking about sexuality,
it's a very important
thing, I think, you know?
Because it dictates a lot of things
that people don't even
want to acknowledge.
Someone said that if you look
at the history of the world,
most of the conflicts
could have been avoided
if people have probably
had better sexual relations
with their partners.
[ Laughter ]
And if you think about it
critically, it's somehow true.
Because someone might
wake up with some kind
of sexual frustration
one way or the other,
and something that is very
insignificant will suddenly take
on a whole new dimension
in his mind.
You know? And then there's
been a lot of trouble
because of people having sex
with people they shouldn't
be having sex with.
You know, someone who is very
reasonable, very rational has sex
with someone he is not supposed
to have sex with and ends
up doing very stupid
things, you know?
And then you have stupid
people having sex
with people they shouldn't have sex
with and are doing smart things.
So it has different kinds
of impacts on people,
and that is essentially what
Binta and Reza were doing.
And then also we don't
want to talk about sex,
we pretend we don't do
it, but that is not true.
I've been asked before, "So,
where is this story coming from?"
I say, "Look at the
population of the north."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, something has to be
happening for all of these children
to be coming from somewhere.
And the truth is that the
north is very conservative.
It is a very religious
community in the sense
that it is religious both ways.
You know, the Muslim
north very religious;
the Christian north is
equally very religious.
So we have all this conflict
of religion, of faith.
And it merges so much
with the culture
that at some point you don't
know where religion ends
and where culture begins.
So people talk about
sex, sexual relationship
in harsh tones, you know?
And I felt it's important to kind
of bring it into the foreground,
into the mainstream of
conversation so that
to understand exactly
what is happening.
The story here is about Binta who,
for the better part of her life,
has been sexually frustrated
because her relationship
with her husband hasn't been
-- you know, wasn't great.
Essentially he was
a stranger to her.
And she just married him out of
obedience to her parents' command.
And for the bulk of her life
when we wanted to take initiative
in sexual relationship, she was
put down very strongly, you know?
And it had an impact on her.
And then after her husband
died, she had this opportunity
of having a relationship with
someone who is much younger
than her, but someone who is capable
of giving her what
she always desired.
And all of a sudden the society
said, "Wait, this is our business.
Who you do things with in our
bedroom is exactly our business.
So we're going to intervene
and do stuff about it."
You know.
>> Patricia Baine: I would ask you,
are you speaking for
women or as a man?
[ Laughter ]
But that's another old question.
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: Yeah.
>> Patricia Baine: Another question
that I do have is when you look
at the literary creations that
are emerging throughout Africa,
throughout the African diaspora,
are there certain trends,
are there certain themes that are
emerging in this literary world?
And where does your work fit
into this new literary trend?
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: Huh.
Well, it fits -- I think I will let
the experts and academic decide.
My job is to write a
book, which I've done.
So I'm giving the academics
something to work with, I hope.
But yes, there's a new voice coming
out of the continent and it is bold.
And some people think
it's irreverent as well.
I think it is both.
And I think it's become necessary
because there are barriers
that have been there for ages
and ages, and those barriers need
to go for whatever reason.
We need to advance, we need to talk
about things we are
not talking about.
Ten years ago, maybe I wouldn't have
written a book like this, you know?
But this, I think, we
need to really talk
about how these relationships
affect the way we think,
the way we grow up, and the way
our society's shaped eventually.
So we are having writers
from different parts
of the continents talking
about things that rotate
in their own societies
and their own communities,
and they're pushing the barriers,
challenging the frontiers.
And I think it's important
because the world is opening up.
And Africa needs to open up as well.
And we can't do that unless we push
down barriers and have conversations
about the things that shape
the way we think, you know?
So that is a very important thing.
And I'm very proud to be
part of this generation
that is challenging those frontiers
and breaking down those barriers.
>> Patricia Baine: Okay.
And my final question to you would
be what steps need to be taken
to bring recognition from
the international community
to African literary scholarship?
Or do you think steps
need to be taken?
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: Well,
of course, there are things
that need to be done, you know?
And I think it starts with us, the
writers and Africans and all of us.
We need to tell our own stories.
We need to believe in our own
stories and believe in our own voice
and tell our stories the
way they should be told.
I think because the publishing
industry based is in the West,
if you like, they are
the gatekeepers.
So they determine which stories
from Africa come out there,
which ones are considered
good enough to be published
by whoever wants to publish them.
But when you have publishers
on the continent --
and we've had a few of them
coming up Nigeria, for instance.
Cassava Republic represented
by Emma Shercliff, you know,
they're doing a wonderful job.
And they've given Africa
writers the boldness
to tell their stories the
way they want it to be told.
And I think that is the
first step, you know?
We need the stories to be available
first before later maybe we can sort
them out and say, "Okay, let's have
a conversation about these things."
But the important thing
is we need to write,
we need to tell our stories.
>> Patricia Baine: Okay.
I thank you.
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: Thank you.
>> Patricia Baine: Again,
I congratulate you
on your debut novel.
At this point we'll have a
Q&A, a brief Q&A session.
And I'd also like to note that
the author will do book signings
down in the gift shop
following this program.
So for any of you who are interested
in books, we'll go to the gift shop.
>> Thank you very much.
I loved the readings and the way you
answer the questions and everything.
So I have a question.
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: Yes.
>> You talk about breaking the
barriers and telling your own story;
can you say something
more about the barriers?
What are the barriers that
are holding back young writers
from writing, potential writers?
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: Yeah.
Okay. For instance, right, from
the north of Nigeria where I come
from where I have spoken about
this rich literary tradition
that we have, we write what
we call Soyayya novels,
which in essence translate
as romance novels, right?
But in these romance novels you
don't have any kind of contacts
between unmarried people in
public spaces, in private spaces.
You don't talk about sex.
You know? And that is the way
the culture has shaped people not
to engage with these issues.
So you have people falling
in love, but you don't talk
about them kissing or
holding hands or -- you know?
And I talk about married people
having relationships and you avoid
as much as you can the issues
of sex, and sexual frustration,
and the consequence of those things.
So those are some of
the barriers that are,
you know, holding people back.
And as far as I'm concerned, they
are issues that need to be tackled
because they are at the heart
of our orientation as a people.
You know? So there are subjects that
are considered taboo in a way --
sexuality and all that -- but then
people are challenging those issues
and they're talking about them now.
And I think it's important to
start these conversations one way
or the other.
So those are some of the issues
that people need to talk about.
Second issue is that the lack
of publishing infrastructure
is a major issue.
And I believe that if you have
enough publishers on the continent,
you know, you have more than enough
stories to tell to the publisher
to be shared with the world.
So yeah, we're getting
there somehow.
[ Inaudible ]
Maybe if you read the book
you'll find out, right?
[ Laughter ]
But then again, it's Nigerian.
So he spoke about certain issues.
I knew [inaudible]
had written a book.
And, you know, he's not the
only prominent northerner
to have written a book.
Tafawa Balewa, the
first prime minister
of Nigeria, was an author as well.
You know? So the tradition
has always been there.
In terms of book promotion,
I think --
I don't know, people kind of place
these expectations on authors to --
and that is because we
don't have the publishing
structure [inaudible].
But people have expectations
on writers to be publishers,
to be book promoters,
to be everything.
It's simply not possible.
Some people are good at
writing, that's what they can do.
promoting other people's work,
and that's what they can do.
So we need the structures, really.
There are people who are
struggling to be writers,
who to be honest shouldn't
even bother.
They should work in
certain [inaudible],
maybe be editors or something.
I have people who have written
books and every day they ask me,
"Where can we find an editor?"
And you have problems
recommending editors to them
because there aren't enough
people training themselves
to become editors.
You know, everybody wants to
write, everybody wants to publish.
It's a challenge.
So there's the need for that
diversification could be there,
you know?
So yeah. Religious
freedom and whatnot,
[inaudible] is a complex case.
You and I know that, right?
People use religion.
And especially the leaders of
that region, they use religion
as a mechanism to suppress people,
to keep them, you know, subjugated.
And it is not right,
it is very wrong.
I remember an instance
where a cousin of mine went
to serve [inaudible], which
is far up in the north.
And the idea of the youth
services, you know, after graduating
from university you dedicate
a year to serve your country.
So you are posted to a different
part from where you come from
and you cannot participate
in some community services.
So when he went there, a permanent
citizen of that area said,
"You know, these are people, the
way you see them, just let them be.
Don't try to influence them,
don't try to change them.
They will never change."
So he couldn't understand.
So after a few weeks there he
realized what was happening.
That man, along with a few others,
[inaudible] people
in that community.
So there is nothing that a
government would want to do
to that community that doesn't
have to come through them.
You know? So they don't want other
people to [inaudible] to come
and participate in whatever's going
on and sharing ideas and all that.
So often they get allocations from
governments and they divert them
to private use and
people don't know.
Because they are the
ones who are -- you know?
So we have this issue.
We have -- I mean, the attacks on
the emir of Kano, for instance,
is he is a religious leader in a
way and he's also a cultural leader,
but he's speaking the
truths to the north.
And the north is not
entirely pleased by that
because they don't expect that
kind of challenge to comes
from its leaders, you know?
So we have issues that
we need to deal with.
And in a way you talk
about religious revivalism,
which started in the north in the
1970's and continued into the '80s.
In a way you want to think it's a
good thing, but then you look at it
and you realize that maybe it's
not such a great thing sometimes.
Because we have now issues
of fundamentalism going
on in the north, you have Boko
Haram and all of them sprouted
from this revivalism and all that.
So it is also suppressing
conversation.
And I think that is where I have
a problem with it, you know?
We need to be more open, we need
to have conversations about things
in a very civilized context.
So yeah.
>> My question kind of has two part.
The first part is about
Nigerian literature
and where you see you fit in.
I consider Nigeria [inaudible] to be
like the diesel engine
of African literature.
It's got history.
So I'm quite sure that it's --
I'd like to hear how you
see yourselves fitting
into that larger fabric.
And the second question is,
is the lid completely off
on African literature
now or are there things
within African societies that will
maybe not allow the level of freedom
of expression that you
might have in the West?
And is the West influencing
some of those topics
and making them more exposed
within African literature?
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: Is
the West having this influence?
Yeah, sometimes we want to look
at the West as the big bad wolf
that is just waiting to eat
up Little Red Riding Hood.
But then in some cases
you look at it
and you say, "Yeah, maybe they are."
Because like I mentioned
earlier, they are the gatekeepers.
They have this publishing
infrastructure.
So they determine what kind
of stories they publish.
Sometimes I want to believe
them, but sometimes I prefer
to take responsibility
for [inaudible] we do.
And I think it's high time
we stopped the blame game
and shifting the buck and
do what we really can do.
It's easy to say that, "Well, I
mean, the West dictates the kind
of stories we tell
because they are the one
who accept the manuscripts
and publish them."
But then if you don't have
people like Cassava Republic
and other publishers challenging
and creating avenues for the stories
to get out, then you have a problem.
You know? The second
question you asked?
>> First actually, the first one,
where do you see yourself as fitting
into that kind of mythical,
you know, or legendary --
this literary -- when
you're [inaudible].
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: I guess
when I get there, I'll find out.
[ Laughter ]
For now I only think about writing
and writing what I hope will
be good stories that people all
over the world would relate with.
I'm very conscious of what I
write about, and I'm conscious
of the background I come from.
But I'm equally very conscious
that I want my stories
to have a universal appeal --
universal in the sense that I
want people in rural England
and maybe small town America
to read the book and connect
to the universal human concern
that my characters share.
Like I said, I am from the
north, and we have this issue of,
if you call like, call
it "othernization,"
you know, everyone is the other.
You know? Even in the
Nigerian context,
not to talk about the
global universal context.
So this othernization is something
I'm really keen on taking down,
you know, and to break down barriers
so that people are conscious
that yes, Hajiya Binta, who is a
character in my novel is a Muslim,
is a northerner; but then
she has universal concerns
that an average American has, that
an average Japanese person has.
So these are the things that
I'm really interested in.
Where I situate myself,
I don't think I'm
in a position to judge yet.
Someday I guess we'll find out.
[ Laughter ]
Yes. Hello.
>> Hello. I was curious
how this model --
and even your earlier
question for stories --
how people reacted
in northern Nigeria?
And, you know, this novel,
is it widely available,
can people read it?
And to what extent have you heard
from, you know, ordinary readers?
And also, I wonder if you've
gotten into any trouble,
if your book has had the
honor of being, you know --
[ Laughter ]
You know, is it in any way
sort of taboo for people
to read it in northern Nigeria?
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim:
Fortunately,
it hasn't gotten to that level.
When the book was launched
in Lagos in November 2015,
I remember there was someone
who was genuinely concerned
for my safety, you know?
And she felt, "Wow, we're talking
about things northerners
don't talk about.
You'll get in trouble."
And she was so concerned
that actually sent me a link
to a residency for
artists who are threatened.
And she strongly encouraged me
to apply just in case [Laughs].
And your questions
about the possibility
of a fatwa being declared against
me, and yeah, at some point you kind
of entertain those concerns.
But what I did is that
I felt that I'd done --
and now this is me going into a
zone that I shouldn't go into --
but I had the confidence that I
had done justice to this issue
in portraying the people of the
north and the north itself in a way
that is not derogatory but in a way
that is frank and honest, that says,
"You know, these are
the issues you have.
And if you look at
yourself in the mirror,
you'll actually see
these issues are there."
And then you reflect,
which is what I want.
People should reflect about
it, and think about it,
and think of making changes.
No, I haven't been
threatened yet [Laughs].
And the book is widely
available in the north.
I think we've gone through several
reprints in Nigeria already.
Yeah, the reception has been good.
And I think I've had reactions
from readers in the north,
women especially who
say, "Well, you know,
this has some really naughty
things you talked about.
But then to be honest, this is us."
You know? And for me, that is the
greatest compliment you could get
from the people you
are writing about.
So.
>> Hi. Just sort of -- your answer
sort of leads into my question
that how did you land on the main
character, a 55-year-old woman,
since typically 55-year-old
women aren't the main characters
of many novels these days?
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: Oh.
[Inaudible], okay.
Yeah, how the story came to me.
I was sitting down, minding
my business, you know,
watching Barcelona [Laughs].
But then I had this vision of
this very rascally person jumping
over a woman's fence and going
into her house to burglar it
and then ends up meeting
the owner of the house.
So I became really curious
about what the burglar
and the person who's being burgled.
And I said, "You know, just
follow them and see what happens."
And that was how the
story came about.
So I've also been really
curious about age
and sexuality, especially
in Nigeria.
It's very common to have a
60-year-old man marrying a girl
who is 17 or 18, you
know, and nobody frowns
about it or nobody frowns at it.
But then if a woman who is 35
is marrying someone who is 27,
you know, it becomes a problem.
What do you mean, she's older?
Old enough to be your mother?
That is what they will tell you.
You know? I remember when
I was in secondary school
and I was dating this girl who
was in the same class as me.
We were the same age.
And I took her to see my mom.
And my mom was very hospitable,
she received her well.
After the girl went, my mom
said, "She's a nice girl,
but she's too old for you."
And I was like, "Okay.
But she's my age [inaudible],
right?"
So when I was 26 I dated a girl who
was 26, same age, same everything.
And, again, of course, I
wanted to marry her then
because I was 26, right,
not 17 or 18.
And my mom said, "Oh, she's a nice
girl, but she's too old for you."
[Laughs] So these perceptions
are common.
In Nigeria it's common that
you should have maybe five,
ten years difference between
a man and a woman marrying;
but the man has to be older, right?
So I was, like, if
we reverse this role,
what if the woman is older
who's having this relationship
with this guy who is much
younger, what happens?
So that was one of the
premise I started off with.
And then again, you have issues
of how would her children react,
how would people around react,
how would they see these issues?
And I felt it's important
because most times when we talk
about the sexuality of older women,
we -- in Nigeria we say sugar mommy.
You know? And the general
perception is that well,
she's going into it for the sex.
And she has to pay the young
guy to agree to sleep with her.
And in this scenario
that is not the case.
Yes, sex was at the heart
of the relationship,
but there was something much more.
For Binta there was this desire to
redeem this character, you know,
the character of Hausa Reza,
to make him a better person
in her own, you know, fashion.
So that was something that was
playing in her mind as well.
So it wasn't really -- I was
trying to break this mold
of older women being sugar
mommies for whatever reason.
People can have relationship
for something much more profound
than for, you know, just the
pleasure of it and then for sake
of making some extra
income or something.
So yeah.
>> I have one last question.
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim:
One last question.
[ Inaudible ]
>> And lastly, any plans
to turn this into a film?
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: The title.
Well, I think the title
came before the book came.
So when I wrote the book,
I kind of wrote the title
into the book so that works.
But then I wanted to capture
something that is beautiful and then
at the same time has several levels
of interpretations, you know?
So a season of crimson
blossoms is a beautiful season.
For Binta, this blossoming
that she had very late
on in her life is something
beautiful.
But then again, it comes
with a price, you know?
So it's beautiful and then it's
-- it's crimson, for god's sake.
It's red, which means
[inaudible], right?
So that's that element.
And there's this element of the
violence, the level of violence
that forms the background of the
story, you know, which is again red.
So those were the things I was
trying to capture in the title.
And the proverbs, yeah.
Yeah, I thought that was a
cute thing to do [Laughs].
So yeah, I wanted to
do that, really.
I put them in when I
was writing this story.
And then at some point
when I was writing,
I thought I should take them out.
And an editor said, "If you
dare touch those proverbs,
I'm going to kill you."
[Laughs] So I decided to leave them.
That's how they ended
up being in the book.
Yeah. But then, again, it's for
me, those proverbs are some kind
of philosophical nuggets, if
you look at them that way.
Sometimes people wanting
philosophies
so [inaudible] the west.
But then when you read our
proverbs, you read them,
you see meanings, you
know, deep meaning.
And you kind of wonder.
And that was what I did.
I wondered who would sit down
and think about this thing
and then phrase them in
such a way that they are
so powerful, and short,
and poignant?
And I thought it's a shame that we
are letting these things go instead.
And I kind of wanted to capture
them and preserve them in my book.
So I'm happy there is
an [inaudible] here.
That's good.
Okay, I have the mic.
So yeah [Laughs].
>> I'm a [inaudible]
student from the University
of Baltimore [inaudible].
I wanted to know what African
literature are you reading?
What is some of your favorites or
what are you reading right now?
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim:
What am I reading right now?
Right now I'm not reading
an African book.
It's titled A Case of Exploding
Mangoes by Hanif Mohammed.
It's Pakistani.
That's what I'm reading
at the moment.
I've been reading a lot
of African novels, a lot.
The most recent is [inaudible].
So yeah, I've had influences,
of course,
from the works of Chinua Achebe.
Every African writer knows, right?
Achebe [inaudible] is one of
my favorite African writers.
You talk about Naguib
Mahfouz, a Nobel laureate.
So yeah, there's this
rich background
of African literature
to draw from, you know?
And I'm delighted we
have this background
and these resources to connect to.
So.
>> Okay.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: Yeah.
I come from Jos.
>> Yes, I know.
[ Laughter ]
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: So
does that answer the question?
[ Inaudible ]
Perhaps yes.
You know, for those
who don't know Jos,
it is a city in central Nigeria,
which is more in the
north [inaudible].
So it's kind of northern
Nigeria, but it's central.
And it's very cosmopolitan.
It has a large population
of Muslims and Christians.
So you live in proximity
to Muslims and Christians.
But then, again, in 2001,
like I mentioned in the novel,
there was a complete
breakdown of law and order
and there were violence between
Muslim and Christians, you know?
And the fact is that Jos is
segregated into small communities
of Muslim groups, your
Christian groups there.
So it's difficult for me not to
associate the Jos I grew up in
with the Jos that exists presently.
There are communities that
are some Muslim when you go
into now you don't feel comfortable
because you feel threatened.
You feel that your
life is in danger.
And there are communities that
if a Christian walks into,
he feels threatened or so.
So that is the reality that I have
today as the background of my life.
And it sort of reflects
in this book, you know?
The fact that I grew up in Jos in
close proximity to all these types
of people gives me the -- I think
the necessary platform to kind
of view all these things from
a very vantaged position.
So yeah, yeah.
Good, thank you.
>> Patricia Baine: One last question
and then we'll close our program.
>> I have a similar question.
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: Okay.
>> You talked about northern
Nigeria and barriers [inaudible].
How much does that reflect what
goes on in the rest of Nigeria?
Are there similar taboos
and barriers?
Is it distinct, like
the [inaudible]?
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim: You
see, the thing is this, right,
Nigeria is a collection of
several countries in one.
I've heard a writer from southern
Nigeria saying that, "Well,
you know, those northerners,
they are closer to Malians
than they are to me as a Nigerian."
Because the cultural
differences are very significant,
you know, hugely significant.
But then again, when you look at
the Nigerian society as a whole,
there are issues that
are common to both.
For instance, the treatment
of widows in the south is --
well, widows in the south of
Nigeria are considerably worse off
than their colleagues in the north
or their counterparts in the north.
But then again, there's this
issue of subjugation of women,
of subjugation of sexuality,
and all that.
And, you know, for me, one
of the things that came
up when people read this
book in Nigeria in the north
and in the south -- the other
writer friend I had from Lagos
who read this book and said,
you know, "I'm a Nigerian,
but reading this book is
like I'm being introduced
to a completely different universe."
And that is the extent
of the divide.
But then there are the issues I
talked about, the universal concerns
that people connect to
wherever they are from.
And one of those is that people
who had lost their fathers 10,
15 years ago, 20 years ago
read this book and they say,
"You know what I don't
like about this book?
It made me think about
my mother's sexuality."
Because the assumptions is
that, "Oh, my father is dead,
so no more sex for
her, no more action,
whatever, and she's done for."
And then you read this book
and you realize, "Well,
she's human, she has
this human need.
She has this."
So I think it has kind of
created some kind of understanding
for people about the
needs of their, you know,
widowed mothers or
something like that.
Yeah, I hope I've somehow
answered the question.
>> Patricia Baine: This
concludes our program.
So we'd like to thank Abubakar.
We'd like to thank Abubakar.
And, again, we will
have a book signing
down in the gift shop
of the Library.
And that's on the ground floor.
>> Abubakar Adam Ibrahim:
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.